hello I'm Bob Rose and I'd like to
welcome you to the 29th
joy of painting series if this is your
first time with us allow me to extend a
personal invitation for you to get your
brushes and your paints and paint along
with us each show and if you've been
with us before please allow me to thank
you for inviting us back for another
series of painting shows we'll use about
a dozen colors at some unorthodox
brushes and each show I'll show you how
to put some of natured masterpieces
right here on the canvas so I tell you
what let's get started
today we'll have them run all the colors
across the screen right there that you
need to paint along with us while
they're doing that let me tell you what
I've got going up here today I'm using
an 18 by 24 inch double-prime
pre-stretched canvas but you use
whatever size you'd like and I've just
covered the entire canvas with a very
thin coat of liquid white the liquid
white is designed just to make the
canvas wet and and to make it slick it
allows us to actually blend color right
here on the canvas makes your whole
painting life a lot easier so let's get
started thought today we just do a very
simple little scene that hope you'll
enjoy let's start with a little two-inch
brush and a touch of the Lisbon crimson
and we just load a little bit right into
the bristles a little paint out tap the
bristles firmly to assure a nice even
distribution of paint all the way
through the bristles and let's go right
up here and we'll take this old brush
and just making little excess little
crisscross strokes we're just very
quickly dropped in just a little more
imparting the sky here maybe we'll have
a little pink in the sky I sort of like
that and in our world we can do anything
that we want to do here any other thing
there doesn't take too long when you
using a brush is 2 inches wide okay
without even cleaning the brush we'll go
right into right into little phthalo
blue
I like fatal blue it's a very warm blue
very nice once again just tap a little
color into it and let's go back up here
and still using a little crisscross
strokes excess it's all they are a
little excess we'll just apply a little
bit of the Thaler blue something about
like so
then we'll come back after we clean the
brush and blend that together now the
blue is many many times stronger in this
little pink area it'll just eat it up so
be careful be careful all go away if you
want to make the indication of a happy
little cloud all you do is just sort of
tap little stringy cloud this lives
right there in the brush and that easy
good blending Mount have a little
stringer clouding there let's see all we
have had on there let's have some water
in this painting I love water and it's
very easy to paint in this style still
water is always level and I think they
will have still water so pull from the
outside in outside in something about
like so alright I'll have a little brush
going I want to darken the corners a
little bit I'm going to take a little
pression blue and just add in the
corners here and there a little bit up
there and we'll go over to the other
side and add a little more and then down
to the bottom we'll put a little down
through to I'm just putting a little
pression blue in each corner to darken
it and then the most fun part of this
whole technique is washing the brushes
since these are oil paints we're washing
our brushes with odorless paint thinner
shake off the excess and just beat the
devil out that's really the most fun
part of it now with a clean brush and
it's relatively dry from just beating it
we'll start in the light area which is
the pink and we'll blend it all together
something about like so so there's two
it came down here we'll just do the same
thing there but it's that easy that easy
what's so fantastic about this is it
anybody anybody can put a little
masterpiece on canvas
with just a little bit of practice a
vision in your mind and off you go
alright that's working so we'll take a
little white a little bit of the blue
and grab a little more of the titanium
why don't make a light blue color here
mostly phthalo blue let's just tap a
little color into the bristles so two
inch brush will do marvelous things
watch here watch your watch it's fun
let's take the corner of the brush and
just pull down something about like so
straight down straight down I'll make it
look like little distant trees live far
back in the distance a little more color
and we'll just have it we go I don't
know right there in your world you
create any illusion that you want there
but I want to keep the bottom light so
it looks like mist you could even take
another to inspiration I have several
and tap it really get in there tap it
and then lift upward it'll help create
that illusion of mist right down at the
bottom and sometimes sometimes it's a
lot of fun to put several layers it
helps create depth in your painting and
for that we'll add a little more blue
but we make it a little darker I had a
little bit of Prussian blue to it make
it a little darker but the same thing it
will come back and let's put another
little layer in here just touching and
pulling downward that's all we're doing
it's really all were doing something
about like it there and we don't know
where that goes it doesn't matter at
this point
and back to our other 2 inch brush we
will tap this I want to create mist
again notice the separation it's caused
because of the difference in color
difference in value and that misty area
turns out to be a very best friend take
care of it
treasure in there okay let's have some
more fun let's see that take some black
some Prussian blue and little phthalo
blue it doesn't matter we just throw it
on there crimson to what the heck be
brave be brave
I hope pull the SAP green in there too
it's getting close enough we should
begin seeing some color a little bit of
white don't want it totally dark yet
they're perfect can we wipe the old
knife off and let's get this hmm
fan brush we use a fan brush loaded full
of color both sides both sides okay a
scope in here and maybe in our world
their lives does now some little trees
back in here now these are a little
closer you're seeing a little more
detail a little more distinct there and
we just drop them in we don't know where
they go wherever you want
that's exactly exactly where they should
live don't put too much detail in here
it's too far away you're not gonna see a
lot of detail you see detail and it's
very close to you things are far away
you make out form shape a basic color
that's all save you detail to the
foreground the lack of detail helps also
create that illusion of distance and
depth in your painting it's very very
important very important okay I won't
tap a little Dada that'll help create
that illusion of mist down there to
there lift slightly upward lightly just
to a little bit see now then you know as
traditional painter one of the hardest
things to make effectively was
reflections watch how easy I'll take
some that same color we'll take a 2 inch
brush touch and pull down just pull
straight down it's most important to go
straight down something like so straight
down because of the noises and very
lightly go across there and instantly we
have some nice reflections that's simple
now here's something is funny take a
little I just use a little white if you
want to create another plane in your
painting take a little white and lift
upward and it'll make little areas back
here that looks like a whole different
plane and the white will end up looking
like little trunks and those trees there
and easy let's put a little water line
for that we use a liquid white
without very flap glad as you can get it
cut across okay and we can go right up
in here and we can just drop in just a
little water line just a happy little
water angle is back in here somewhere we
don't know where it is don't know that
we even care just let your imagination
take it anywhere you want to go a lot of
times I started painting and have
nothing in mind but the time of day and
the time of year and from that you can
paint some fantastic little scenes don't
worry about it you don't always have to
have a perfect vision in your mind of
what it is you're going to paint
imagination is it's it's like any other
muscle in your body or like your muscle
anybody the more you practice the better
it becomes take some black depression
blue I'm gonna put some phthalo green in
there I like sailu green maybe a little
crimson there we go all right let me
wipe off the knife I just wiped the
knife on a little little paper towel I
would just use that brush a little fan
brush load some color into it both sides
of the brush both sides of scope in here
let's have let's have a little evergreen
tree he lives right there see just make
a line take the corner of the brush make
a touch make another one and just sort
of work from the center out there goes
it's easier to do them faster at his
slow though here they come just sort of
back and forth I had a lady in class one
time told me it was like making ZZZ the
letter Z she called him Z trees so I
guess that's as good of analogy as any
from the center out the center of the
tree should be the thickest darkest
strongest part of the tree because you
have leaves on the back you have a trunk
in the middle and you have leaves on
this side we have one more in there
there we go I have a little family of
trees
you know if you painted with me before I
think everybody should have a friend
even a tree even a tree needs a friend
if you want to reflect those just pop in
some general indications of where they
are no big deal see because we don't
make mistakes here we have happy
accidents very quickly
you learn to work with anything it
happens take the big brush pull down
straight down once again and then go
across and we have instant reflections I
just use the same fan brush it has that
color we made the tree out of it I go
through CAD yellow and little yellow
ocher immediately we have green there we
are let's go up in here now we can take
that green let's go back and put some
highlights on our little evergreen trees
there to go all right
this little tree here he's saying don't
leave me out I need some tone there we
are all right now put a little liquid
white right on the same brush as I want
to lighten the color and make it a
little thinner at the end paint will
stick to a thick paint we mix them back
up again let's go back up here and we
can just take this brush let's just pop
in the indication of some little bushes
that live down here right down in these
little foots something about like it has
happened it looks like a little island
let's put some dirt there let's take
some white a little dark Sienna mix them
together cut off a little roll of paint
let's go up in here and we'll take this
and we just put the indication here a
little bit of soil some dirt some
kindness gotta have a place that this is
a little island for all this to settle
all right let's see there all there is
to it okay
all right we got to figure out something
to do on the other side now let's have
some fun
that's has some fun you know if you've
painted with me before I like I like all
the big trees let's take a little bit of
that color right there
let's go rap in here this is your
bravery test take the corner the old
two-inch brush and let's just begin
laying in a basic shape here tree it
lives right there
right big old tree but he's a nice tree
very yes all right all I got that brush
going tell you what maybe let's do
something about like this and we just
happen all kinds of little little bushy
looking areas you have to decide what
lives here how far it goes how tall is
it how short is its fat skinny in
between it's your world and in your
world you make all the decisions all the
decisions there we are
see we just put in some dark in here so
later on our light color will show there
this grandpa oops grab now there's a fan
brush right there
take a little white a little bit of the
dark sienna just want to make the
indication here maybe a little tree
trunk maybe a little more dark see how
much that's nice okay right here just
want some indications I'm gonna put some
happy little leaves on there so we're
gonna cover most of those up most of
them won't show we'll go right into that
little SAP green a little bit of the
yellow we just put right on this two
inch brush give a little push good shot
there you can see that will hey let's go
up in here now I want to put some leaves
on here use chest the corner of the
brush just the corner of the brush there
we go see others to it
just the corner think about shape and
form drop these little rascals in
wherever you want wherever you really
are the creator on this piece of canvas
you can do anything can move rivers
mountains create any illusion that you
want here and I go home the only power I
have is over the garbage chuck I can
take it to the street all by myself but
here I can do anything absolutely
anything I decide the one to Bush right
there and tell you what let's get crazy
you know me if you pay me with me before
I like big trees and we have one living
in our world right there
there re Council we should have done
this with the two inch brush you'd been
a lot faster there we go
just drop it in wherever you think it
should be all right last big tree Howard
kiddin this is a monster tree huge tree
and you could have done it with a
two-inch brush just as easy with much
quicker I like the old fan brush it
gives you a little more detail here we
go with my smaller tree because I think
he needs a friend
there okay just drop it in
all we're doing in once again is putting
in the background color you could put
this in with a with a paint roller it
doesn't matter
long as the shape was right he'll come
back and separate all of this with some
nice highlights his little brown and
white we've put the indication just here
and there of a trunk just what you can
see here and there there you don't see
it all as you have leaves on this side
go back to our little fan brush go right
through the CAD yellow yellow ochre load
some color into it let's go back up in
here let's put a highlight or two on
here evergreens are normally darker than
other trees so don't don't kill all the
dark hair Union and you evergreen it
happens sometime gets feeling good and
you don't go in to stop there and the
base of the tree should be darker than
the top big shadow areas underneath in
those shadows areas of where all my
little friends live in previous shows
we've had like Peapod the pocket
squirrel a little squirrel that lives
with me we've had him on the show but
this is kind of places that he likes
let's take a little bit of color let's
use the let's use the one-inch brush
we'll go through some get some SAP green
some yellow load a lot of color into the
brush or SAP greens that's nice
alright then we can go up here and we
can begin picking out individual bushes
one at a time one at the time there's a
happy little Bush he lives right there
do you know he was there didn't and he's
got a little friend named Clyde is right
over here there he is
so you can give all these things names
personalities shoots okay I'll take the
little oval brush dip in some paint
thinner I'll go through some midnight
black and some brown or once unloaded
full of color I can
then I'm gonna take and with the other
side I'm gonna cuss some light brown I
made earlier I'm just going to go
through see like that little black in it
make it a little - oh that's nice
now with that I just want to come up
here and make the indication we can't
see them too much of some rocks that
live up there just some happy little
rocks maybe there's one there something
wherever just some indications they
won't come back with our brush we were
making the bushes with and we'll settle
those right down into the painting there
now see how they become part of the
painting there we go like so it will
make all kinds of little bushes and
trees and happy little things that live
here in our world all right okay shoot
we had such a places that I'd have to go
fish it there I like to fish but I'm not
a very good fisherman I catch a little
fish and take the hook carefully out of
his mouth and put a bandaid on him
little CPR pat him on the tutu and put
him back in the water
go back catch him again another day but
we'd have to have way to get up here
please go to catch that fish it would
take a little the Van Dyck Brown and
let's have us a little path we had to
walk all through these bushes mosquitoes
of get us off let's have us a little
path that we can walk back in here catch
a big ol trout or bass whatever it is it
lives in here there take a little bit up
find some white little dark sienna mix
it together make a little highlight
color just barely touching barely let it
graze let it graze that easy that easy
that like so
okay they're at it let's put something
on this side you have something on the
other side to pass now let's go on this
side
once again I'm take a one inch brush
notice that it's straight down and I'm
pulling it in one direction it's most
most important that loads a lot of paint
and see it rounds one edge you want to
turn it put that rounded edge to the top
it's most important and then we take
that and we go right up in here
no pressure hardly just enough to get to
brush to touch the canvas and we begin
working on shape and form and we create
a bush or a tree that lives right there
so others to it and there's another one
but do one at a time I know I know
sometimes it starts working you get
greedy do one at a time one at a time
put a little bright red on there maybe
here's one right here
oh yeah it's got little I don't know if
you can see I got little red flowers on
the tip mmm sneaky there we go back over
in here and we can begin adding in just
little things that come from out here on
the path dot like Cappin all right
all right you got your brushes warmed up
yet and you're ready you can do this you
can do this I know you can I get letters
every day from people all over the
country that's said they never believed
they could paint and they're doing it
their friends and neighbors don't
believe it when they look at their
paintings but they they are doing it
there I'm gonna put a little sticklers
right there little tree maybe maybe
maybe this little tree died and he's
naked now just a skeleton hanging out
here and that happens in nature there so
we can put little arms on him that are
still hanging out all right
all kinds of little deuter's maybe over
in here and these little details are
what will make your painting look a
little more finished take your time when
you're doing these and just drop them in
here and there and there wherever take a
little light brown with paint thinner on
it and when you mix this get it very
thin this this should be almost like you
almost ink consistency turn the bristle
subtle bring it to a very sharp point
there you can see it good against that
dark all right and where it's very dark
then we make little light trees where
it's light we make dark trees because
they're both exist in nature so you can
put little seeds a little tree lives
back here just has a good time looks out
over the water talks to the fish that's
all there's to it another way of making
little sticks and twigs take your knife
just a clean clean knife and you can
reach up in here and just scrape right
through the paint see and that'll make
all kinds of little sticks and let's
come down here we'll make a few more in
here wherever you decide where they live
sometimes these Oh evergreens here have
old dead limbs hanging off of and you
can do that just with a little flick of
the knife and shoot with that I think we
better have a finished painting it's
that easy let's take a little bit of the
paint thinner a little bright red and
we'll sign this little rascal
I really hope you've enjoyed it it's a
very simple painting that you can do and
if you try it I'd love to see some
photographs of what you're doing so if
you have time take photographs in to us
let us hear from you until then from all
of us here I'd like to wish you happy
painting and god bless my friend
you